là je me lance pas sur les connaissances
que là je vais je vais tous les manger
les dégoûts ville comme quoi ça va tout
casser la satar sang et eau et
maladroite on est à 7 ou 10 mois 4 c'est
vrai que la grossesse ça donne dix fois
plus d'énergie
abba carrément vingt quinze fois plus
même ouais y'a plus absurde humour
absurde soit la nfl fait un atelier
théâtre
bon là ça va pardon excusez moi pardon
tu sais ça ça doit être une allergie
non c'est la grossesse mais celui-ci a
carrément vachement de pollen en ce
moment c'est un support maire d'arette
on peut la lire être à notre regard des
viandes et les 30 en jeu ma tartine de
billets actuels tous les matins ok je
peux rien bouffer parce que j'ai agi en
toute la journée j'ai quand même brice
des petits nouveaux ok jetant page dans
l'hyper mal parce que la vue c'est là au
vu du déroulement des acides et demi
j'ai publié dans deux bus du monde plus
donc ça soit pas avec toi se foutait de
ma gueule parce qu'après la naissance de
inepte a pleuré pendant six mois non
stop donc moelleux et bah moi donc j'ai
de la voir nous oui
as t elle c'est sûr on me regarde et
avec des filles sexy mais moi je vais
leur dire je leur montrais sur les
réseaux regarde je veux montrer que
c'est vraiment sur l'emballage ou à tout
en me touche pas chez nous
[Musique]
salut je suis votre enfant juin du futur
que je t'appelle ricotta appelé ricotta
non je déconne moment écoute moi ma
force de plein de pâques grossesse
toutes les femmes elles ont compris que
tomber enceinte c'est l'enfer bah écoute
tant mieux maintenant j'attends mieux en
2039 n'a aucune femme qui veut faire des
gosses ils sont tous là ils sont tous
terrorisés de tomber enceinte de
l'accouchement de tous hamon la terre
est en train de crever la route arrête
tes conneries et merdier plus d'unités
mais j'aurais bien de futurs ton
portable
il ré édition attend m'éclate allait
vraiment en train de crever là
c'était un garçon une fille
non non mais j'ai essayé de faire comme
l'acier sur le dol d'accord elles sont
comme ça et comme son nom repli s'est tu
lèves way arrête d'essayer dé fronce les
sourcils et ferme un peu de la bouche
j'arrive pas à ton truc la table mais ça
me saoule réponse est pas envie non non
encore fait quelque chose qu'il fallait
pas ouais au nom surpopulation arrêtez
avec vos potos t'a donné envie aux gens
à ok votre action sa gamme les photos
donc et dans 16 ans vellacott du bruit
dans ma chambre pour par andré toqués
avant ok avant ok
[Musique]